là pour le coup on est on a de la chance
[Musique]
donc là on attend les nouveaux trains
parce que généralement il y a entre les
nouveaux et les vieux et les vieux ils
ont une marche donc c'est compliqué un
peu de les de monter c'est pour ça on
doit attendre les agents pour qu'ils
nous ramène une rampe mais les nouveaux
trains sont même niveau par rapport au
quai du coup moi je me mets sur les deux
roues et je peux monter directement
c'est dommage qu'on a pas vraiment assez
de ces trains c'est pour ça quand
j'arrive sur la gare j'attends des fois
un passage de passage trois passages de
train et généralement c'était vieux
train
[Musique]
là il faut faire comme on peut soit
prendre un bus ou bien à aller en
roulant je sais que normalement de là
jusqu'au mon gymnase et à peu près 10
minutes donc je pense que ce qu'on va
faire
là on arrive au Paris basket fauteuil on
a mis à peu près une heure comparé à une
personne valide il peut faire 20 minutes
30 minutes maximum
[Musique]
des jeux je trouve que c'est un peu un
scandale parce que je pensais que les
Jeux paralympiques justement d'avoir les
jeux à domicile ça va être un tremplin
justement pour faire changer les choses
changer les mentalités
améliorer l'accessibilité c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup de travaux pour que
les trottoirs sont un peu surélevés pour
que quand on descend la rampe le bus
soit pas trop que la rampe soit pas trop
inclinée mais voilà on se cache derrière
une fausse solution pour moi parce que
je pense que il aurait fallu au moins
certains stations de métro aurait dû
être accessibles
[Musique]